you know what a cool movie treatment
[__] Steve Green as an HOA leader in
a black neighborhood oh yeah dude fuing
sick I can't do
anything my hands are
[Music]
tied Hey so uh you know for the parents
of the room right yep it's us you guys
get a lot of sleep when you have
newborns honestly I I haven't been sleep
I've been sleeping like [__] answer's
all fat I've been sleeping like [__]
recently cuz my dogs keep waking me up
in the mid your first 6 to 9 months is
[__] crazy cuz they got to feed like
every 2 3 hours so the baby's going to
cry every 2 to 3 hours you got to get up
and you got to feed the baby and then
you got to put the baby back to sleep so
that whole process can take 30 minutes
to an hour so imagine going to sleep at
like let's say 10:00 waking up at 12:00
going back to sleep at 1: waking up at
3:00 going back to sleep at 4:00 waking
up at 5: bro Hannah's mom had four kids
back to back how the [__] did she do it
if you right now did you know that
penguin parents sleep for just a few
seconds at a time to guard newborns so
if you're telling that store to a
penguin right now it's going to be like
be like are you [__] kidding me dude
few seconds they be like this [__] gu
dude this guy right here he gets our me
dude you kidding me right now dude I get
one second of sleep you can't just y
it's kind of cool when they when they
when they marching around with a little
egg in between they're like playing
soccer I love that and then there's a
there'll be a [__] that lost their egg
and they steal it from another mom is
that what their female penguins are
called the bit they call them [__] or
[__] are the [__] are the young
ones uh so chinstrap penguins in
Antarctica need to guard their eggs and
chicks Around the Clock in crowded noisy
colonies to to ward off Predators so and
this is a a brand new study we didn't
know about this until very recently um
but so they knot off thousands of times
a day but only for about four 4 seconds
at a time W how do you a thousand how do
you monitor it what if they're just what
dude what if they're actually just not
even sleeping and they're like how do
you know they put a brain scan on them
scientists told me yeah I I don't
believe it hey they be watching I don't
believe it they be watching them hey you
know that Arctic station that they got
in the [__] Antartica yeah the the
the South Poles mhmm so is that station
there just to study
penguins
I think it's a Nazi Outpost I think it's
cuz I think there's two things they do
they study penguins and then they study
they [__] stick that pipe all the way
down to get ice samples of ancient ice
oh oh bacteria maybe so I can waste
everyone's time telling us how old the
ice is they they're probably trying
to sh gives a [__] you know you know
what you know what the oldest ice in the
world is the ice in the JK fridge yo
they should do a test tube of that they
should core sample that [__] they're
like this is from from 200000 BC I don't
know how a a freezer can have so much
Frost that it grew like that much I
never seen that it got so the JK freezer
got so bad that you couldn't even fit a
microwave burrito in there you had to
like really [__] dig it yeah and
every time I opened it it just wh it
looks like a white Carl's Bad
Cavern looks like a stalagmite up in
there dude that's crazy I'm surprised we
fit anything in there did smack all
honesty all honesty when she was helping
you with the bathrooms and stuff was she
like holy [__] [__] the whole time
yeah yeah yeah she was just like it's
such a guys's Place yeah yeah every
little
thing she's not wrong no yeah did she
think it was like American dudes or
manly and Australian dudes yeah
definitely American dudes are way cooler
than aussy dude keep the creamer for 20
years we got clean that's just you guys
we got cleaners we got cleaners so these
penguins right how do they monitor them
dude yeah check this out they watch him
go like
that and they film it
you would you guys ever eat
penguin no I mean would they could yeah
I have you have hell no dude I ain't a
[__] psycho but see how we view you
that's how cool you are that's how cool
you are like if this guy told me he ate
a penguin I'd be like shut the [__] up
you would say regardless I feel like the
bigon a I would do the big one but not
the little one anon's had it like
delivered when he was I like he had it
delivered
live he had it walked over that fool
came with a backpack and [__] dude is
this the one you want cool he [__]
hits it on the table and it's all days
and then he kills it he picks it out of
a taxi he like that one in the back seat
have you seen the penguin that goes
shopping no no I love that I already
love that looks delicious yeah there's a
penguin in Japan that the owner taught
him like a route to go to the fish
market and then so he would go with his
little [__] penguin backpack and then
the fish guy would stuff the backpack
with the Penguin and then he would get
the money out of it and then the penguin
gets a treat with a little fish I love
that wow dang good thing peta's not
around there fcking [__] Peta I don't
know where they're at have you ever
heard of penguin being sold or like
served served no I've never heard I've
never heard of it come to think of it
I've never heard of it which is tastes
good I feel like you would be served in
like a place like Iceland or something
like some cold ass place or Antarctica
where that's their Chicken Alaska served
in Antarctica yeah do they have penguins
in Alaska no I just looked at it's got
to be like fried penguin or something
yeah probably tastes like chicken but a
little bit of like fish yeah like
everything else also other news you guys
see this video too oh my
God this is a
bear wow taking down a reindeer taking
down a reindeer yeah this bear wants to
win first place oh [__] he's Jewish bear
like where's the me he's double dipping
today they're calling him the Jewish
bear he's like [__] Christmas bro so
he's the Jew Bear Jew bear Jew Bear yeah
bad why cuz he doesn't like Christmas no
he doesn't like Christmas he thinks
Christmas sucks he's turned them all off
yeah maybe he can't sleep with the
lights like that he goes I could see it
from the forest can't believe he's
actually taking him down yeah he's like
he's like the ho says you
know yeah have you seen those ho way
into the woods it's the best he like no
illumination past 9:00
p.m. bleeding in our Windows yeah yes I
I've been I've been going down one of
the hot be vids this weekend I've been
going down the rabbit hole of HOA ring
camera videos where the HOA leaders come
up to the the door and then they'll just
talk mad [__] [__] you guys have HOA
leaders any of you guys nope yes and and
how are they to deal with got rid of the
last guy so it's all it's much more
pleasant oh really got rid of them
you're ho leader they live in your
community uh-huh I don't even know who
are they are they have another board and
we had some of the main Bad Eggs
replaced because they [__] with us too
much oh with your guys' street yeah I
told you guys about this how do you get
nominated to be a board leader um you
it's a process but these guys weren't on
the board they were on this like
Committee of like enforcers who like go
around and do little clipboard [__] and
we had them all replaced just about
replaced as in they no longer have the
role but they still live in the
community they live in the community
they don't have the role that's tight
was it like seeing them on the street a
good you go hi the best are they all sad
now I mean they were always sad do they
not decorate their house they do one of
them does yeah pisses me off what's the
typical type of person that does that do
they just have like how do they have the
time they're Hall monitors dude are they
like Housewives or something yeah
they're like that [__] oh bored ass
Housewives all that kind of [__]
although one of them's a dude and he's
like a little [__] is he like a Ken you
know there's Ken's and Karens he's like
a Ken yeah Kevin he's a Kevin is that
you said he's like a can like a can a
can I was like sure let's hit him the
female I mean I thought that was the
male Ken can would be cool cuz if I was
an HOA like leader or whatever I don't
think would give a [__] about anything
dude as long as your grass is green then
I'm good dude but then he'd be like and
someone gu some guy's like what color is
green e anyway and then Ken's like true
yeah I never thought about it like that
you're right and then the whole
neighborhood's just [__] up my
modalities have shifted my modali you
know what I don't like confrontation too
much because if I was a HOA leader and
someone broke the rules I would just
vandalize their house oh [__] I think
that's breaking rul but then you're
breaking your own rules I would be
probably bringing down the property
value in my own Street doing that but I
would rather do that then talk to them
that's fair that's a good point would
you would you make it so that people
can't like smoke weed in their backyards
cuz the whole neighborhood could smell
it no I'd be like everyone should smoke
it cuz I want second hand you have to
smoke weed you got to be way more chill
that's the rule it's the HOA rule you
know what's a cool movie treatment
[__] Steve Green as an HOA leader in
a black neighborhood oh yeah dude
sick I can't do
anything my hands are tied it's it's a
crazy ass seasonal movie Man Capers
you'll get into the Capers n Dude That's
like [__] tiptoes through the tulips
dude oh [__] that's a good name of the
movie tulip and it's like notoriously
the rowdiest neighborhood and Steve
moves in He's The Ho he's voted the HOA
leader and he has to regulate I'm living
Let Live bro cuz I always joke about the
first thing I would do if I joined the
board is I would dissolve the board cuz
like a power move yeah I don't like
government I don't like mods how would
you keep your streets c yeah you're yeah
I remember now then it becomes all dirty
and gross and then then what would you
do need car you just you what you do is
you actually tell talk to people talk to
their face get them to self-govern
correctly and that's what I think is
what people should do anyway if I have a
problem with anybody in this room I will
just say hi what's up with this I think
it's much easier to get them evicted
yeah I think it's easier to sneak
through the darkness and then complain
to someone on the phone and then they
write a letter and then they send it to
you and it's like [__] made [__] four
steps to tell somebody what you need to
tell them yourself if if it's that bad
you got
to them yeah it's [__] but then I
would just say why do I have to listen
to you you're just a white guy yeah yeah
yeah that's how do you comat all right
good point my method is still the best
there's nothing a
lighter you got a
point I'll tell you what did you say I
seen 22 of you in the JK DMS just this
morning so there's Steve's method of
using reason and empathy and logic and
there's mine which is gasoline and
lighter and I think the vandalism you're
talking about wait why is mine empathy
don't don't say I'm a [__] boy yeah I
don't think empathy is [__] boy
actually I think it's [__] boy [__] I
think it's being able to understand but
these [__] boy [__] you're smarter
godamn it you're able to conflict
resolve better but I think my method is
much easier cuz you burn their house
they don't even have anything to live in
that's true but how do you how how do
you but my property value goes down how
do you not get caught and then your
neighborh looks like [__]
burn house it might be a cool aesthetic
you know what I mean like you know I'm I
don't know I'm going for like the more
Ukraine look and like I don't know like
War torn what if okay let's just let's
just participate in this jalian scenario
what if they to retaliate they start
building their houses out of metal
ooh it's over what happens then metal
yeah turn up the heat so it
melts it can't melt it can't melt
this ain't no 911 steel
beam Anthony told me it can I have to
watch anti Anthony metal I'm going to
pour sea water all over it so it rusts
and then crack it with a hammer
stainless steel [__] now what stainless
steel it's over for you it's done right
what else you got what else you got your
even your own men are are starting to
think about turning on you cuz like this
isn't working anymore yeah there's a
mutiny on your hands stainless steel
houses damn that's a heavy house your
own son your son who you're grooming to
to replace you he's like maybe I should
take over quicker you put fire on the
outside You Can't Fight Fire with Fire
so you use water and you flood the house
oh can't stop this man you guys got to
watch Avatar the Last air bender it
taught me the four elements of vandalism
you have water fire air and Earth that's
all you need all vandalism yeah you have
the four elements of vandalism what's
the air when you just go in their house
the Earth is you get manure like the
French protesters and then you [__]
cover their house and [__] Earth is
manure that's good that's Earth not
rocks and then what's wind or air loud
noise air air L noise [__]
[__] [__] [__]
[__] my echo's like crazy in the
house and I'm like shut up and then fire
and water just literally fire fire and
water just fly where are the other two
so
tracked what's [__] [__]
you in I tap out I tap out yeah this guy
he's evil mastermind he can't be stopped
you're right dude and imagine being the
chosen one that wields all
four